yeah let's talk some nba okay your
knicks lost my mavericks lost yep
what do you think of that in general
lebron lost do you have any interest
anymore in the playoffs
no i mean this is the worst thing that
could have happened to the nba yeah
like nobody wants to see an atlanta
hawks
yeah like no one cares about that series
like they're bringing out
wwe wrestlers to get some interest in
the game yeah
i'm enjoying it but i know and i'm
always like oh big market team
that's what we all say is fans you need
the big market teams because casuals are
done
the clippers you don't give a [ __ ] about
the clippers you know it's you know
what's really interesting is like
people go people say there's criticism
of like boxing or mma and that kind of
stuff like that it's like oh
you're destroying the sanctity of the
sport like how are you going to let
these youtubers and these influencers
into the sport blah blah blah it's like
they are the knicks they are the lakers
right they have the big market team
they bring in the casuals right nobody
wants to see the indiana pacers
play the atlanta hawks that would be the
worst eastern conference finals
in the history it reflects in the
ratings anytime there's not one of these
massive market teams or dynasties
in the ratings it's always down
absolutely abysmal i mean they changed
the playoffs
hoping that the warriors would get in
yeah right they literally change
the format of the playoffs please get
steph curry in there please
please we need to make money on this
first round because we know lebron are
making it past that
yeah and so now we're gonna have to
watch the phoenix suns and the [ __ ]
utah jazz
i mean again i'm gonna enjoy it i don't
blame anybody who's like that [ __ ]
sounds awful
yeah yeah i just don't care i haven't
been as invested even the nets with all
their all-stars it's just like
all right they just turn it on and then
they just have a blowout
yeah like it's like it's not even that
far the nets aren't even that hateable
like they're so
how are you that boring as a super team
yeah i know
it is kind of weird you know what it is
with the net specifically is that um
if if we if this was the world cup
the nets would be the we don't have a
country team
you know like you know in like the
olympics where you compete
for yourself right because you can't
compete on behalf of your country
yeah so it's like if your country got
banned like russia got banned so you got
to compete on behalf of yourself like
ain't nobody give a [ __ ] about you
competing for you right this guy be
bigger than you
and no one cares about the nets i don't
care who you are maybe if you're a new
jersey fan but if you were from new
jersey you're a knicks fan let's keep it
a buck
nobody was a nets fan i went to nets
games as a kid because the tickets were
way cheaper
same with clippers right like you just
go to because your dad wants you to sit
closer to the floor
yeah like you could actually sit pretty
close as a kid
and it was an amazing experience but
there were no nets fans there was no
nets fans then
there's no net fans now so now you have
this super team
but nobody really cares about it if the
nets win nobody in new york will care
about it
you know what people are going to argue
with we're going to fake it we're but
it's not going to mean anything
no here's a perfect argument to your
point and i if you're born in brooklyn
you're a nets fan
fine i don't blame you but nobody is
talking about how good it is that the
nets are good
when the knicks had three playoff games
at home yeah all you heard about was man
it's so good to have the garden rocket
yeah
oh my god like i saw people in dallas
being like dude i got emotional watching
that like new york basketball's back
nobody's doing that for the nets yeah
you